me watching he takes the knife to her
the laughing while he does it
he turns to me and he says why is so
serious
forty to entertainment is a company out
of Pasadena and we were brought in to
create an experimental marketing
campaign and alternate-reality
experience around the dark night the
community was very split about how Heath
Ledger was gonna play one of the most
iconic villains of all time Jack
Nicholson had put an amazing stamp on
the character in the first film and he
hadn't really done anything similar to
this there was a lot of question about
whether or not he could play this
villain how do you close that gap of
that uncertainty in the public vein so
we put a spotlight on that character the
filmmakers wanted to get that very
specific first image of Heath and Joker
makeup out to the community Chris wanted
to create a very real universe it had to
be a very organic looking makeup this
guy's sleeping in his clothes for a week
his hair is oily and greasy and he
doesn't take off his makeup for three to
five days I'm a trained makeup artist
and at first the lines are very clown
like and it looked like a makeup artist
did it and it just wasn't right and then
Fred snowland brought in these Francis
Bacon paintings he's very blurry images
that really set the tone that was our
Bible and set us in a direction of
muting down and degrading the makeup I
was a little nervous a few times trying
to keep the continuity going we would
spread sheath space and I would paint
colors over it you get all these crow's
feet in the corners of his eyes his
forehead expression those were strategic
mark so we always hit what I know what
these scars I couldn't even tell was he
one of the first images that we ever saw
of the Joker was the picture that was
released when we started the alternate
reality experience we had put a little
teaser on the Warner Brothers site where
he could find the I believe in Harvey
Dent campaign poster in comic book
stores or Joker cards
I believe in Harvey Dent too and so they
followed the cards to a URL where they
put in their email and that allowed them
to take a pixel away from the campaign
poster revealing the first image of the
Joker it caught on fire it was a very
effective and dramatic way to change the
conversation the fans really felt like
they were a part of it because it was
something that they had discovered I
think we all do we want to be previous
vegetable Heath that's the Joker it was
revelatory it was transformational I
have never felt such an emotional draw
to a character that did not have good
intentions he made it look effortless
just know exactly what was gonna happen
what was going on it was amazing to
watch could not take your eyes off of
him his relationship with that men in
that film the unstoppable force meeting
the immovable object it's one of the
greatest relationships between
superheroes it's become iconic this
whole image it was an amazing situation
to be involved in and we're still
talking about it so many years later his
performance was just amazing he will
always be the Joker